E aí
[Música]
e Imaginem uma jovem adolescente com
cerca de 16 anos quando se dirigia para
um metro deparava com alguns sem-abrigo
que estavam a pedir roupa sapatos
alimentos para as suas crianças e para
os seus bebés rapidamente percebeu que a
língua não era a mesma eles eram romenos
Mas isso não foi um problema porque
através de uma agenda de um relógio foi
fácil marcar dias e encontros para os
ajudar e para levar os baixo que eles
precisavam através da ajuda de vizinhos
e amigos esta jovem foi adulta muito
cedo teve que assumir responsabilidades
muito cedo e que ajudou a olhar para a
vida com outros olhos
e é tornou a mais próxima e a sentir as
realidades dos outros de outra forma com
mais intensidade E daí ter surgido
empatia que ela ainda nem sabia que
palavra é esta e já acompanhava o curso
psicologia veio da necessidade de
compreender senhora se e o outro e o
voluntariado acompanhou a sempre ao
longo da sua vida consciente por mais
porque temos temos sempre algo de bom
para partilhar com o outro e contribuir
assim para melhorar a vida de alguém
empatia permite estar atenta outro Estar
atento e dar o que nós temos de melhor
ao outro é uma habilidade socioemocional
a aula que nos compreendem compreender a
perspectiva do outro e de experimentar
reações emocionais através da observação
do outro é capacidade de se colocar no
lugar do outro da sua dor e
eu queria sem nos curarmos a nossa
própria permita as pessoas ajudarem são
umas às outras através do amor do
interesse pelo próximo e agir de acordo
com os seus valores e com os seus
princípios Morais queriam uma grande
vontade de compreender e de conhecer e
principalmente aceitar o outro
o congresso a madeira há cerca de cinco
anos após a minha separação e com os
meus três filhos foi colocada a dar
apoio a Várias escolas do 1º ciclo do
Funchal para além de todas as atividades
inerentes as minhas funções sente a
necessidade de ir mais além e de começar
a semear esta empatia nas escolas
através do disco do projeto a descoberta
de empatia sentir que é possível fazer a
diferença na vida dos outros tão projeto
ajuda as crianças a se conhecerem melhor
emocionalmente e aos outros a se
colocarem no lugar do outro através do
exemplo trazendo para a sala de aula
situações do seu dia a dia geradoras de
conflito e em conjunto procurarmos
respostas posso ajudar a lidar com esses
mesmos conflitos os meninos chegarem a
sala professora eu não sei quantos bateu
uma e o teu furioso e o bate lá e eu
disse - Calma
a respirar
e vamos parar e agora olham para aqui
tô pensando vocês e vocês fazem outro
papel e agora em conjunto vamos se
encontrar alternativas que é que vocês
podiam ter feito diferente o que vocês
acham pensem sintam com o vosso coração
e essas ferramentas que eles próprios é
que as descobrem não são aqueles Tiggo
e a são tão simples como professora a
minha ajuda muito quando eu estou muito
irritado e muito furioso ir à casa de
banho lavar a cara Fantástico Somos por
isso com ajuda do professor no cimo da
sala que eu estou despedirem ver a minha
ajuda respirar fundo 50 vezes Fantástico
me ajuda me ouvir música Fantástico eles
próprios encontram as cores ferramentas
e por isso nós vamos ao seu encontro
Ah e não é só de conflitos que nós
falamos da empatia não está bem fazemos
e outras coisas que Tragam ao de cima o
que eles tenham de melhor existe uma
atividade Espetacular que eu adoro e que
eles todos estão sentados em círculo e
cada um se levanta AVC diz gosto muito
meu vizinho que tem os olhos azuis e
todos olham uns para os outros e quem
tem os olhos azuis diz sua professora e
levanta-se todo contente porque alguém
reparou e alguém está a elogiar e a
importância do elogio e quantas vezes
nós nos esquecemos de mostrar ao outro e
dizer e de verbalizar o que o outro
tempo tão bom e como Isto é importante
na vida de todos nós sempre possível
também eles reconhecerem os seus erros
Ainda bem que assim o fazem eu conheço
tantos adultos não tem essa capacidade o
Saber pedir desculpa olha para dentro de
si
se conhecerem melhor e tornarem-se mais
resilientes perante os desafios da vida
que eles são colocados motivar para a
prática da meditação relaxamento como
fundamento essencial para que se
conectarem com sigo e com outro
despertá-los para a prática de atos de
bondade os que estão mais próximos que
os que estão ao nosso lado a nossa
família os nossos amigos os nossos
sonhos temos tanta coisa em casa que não
precisamos e podemos ajudar e podemos ir
entregar em conjunto A uma instituição
ajudar nas tarefas de casa estar atenta
Quem está sozinho e fazer uma visita
que faz toda a diferença em que se sente
que é possível fazer a diferença na vida
dos outros a uns um projeto Espetacular
que teve o seu início no continente que
é a caixa solidária Nossa em casa quando
eu tive conhecimento esse projeto disse
meninos e eu tenho três filhos um contra
eles e Gêmeos com oito anos e disse -
vamos por este projeto em prática aqui
na nossa zona vejamos a caixa escolhemos
a caixa pudesse ser fechada colocamos
alimentos dentro que não se podiam
estragar arranjamos os cartazes em que
diz leva o que precisar e deixou quiser
temos um espaço um espaço público que
todas as pessoas passam e desde o
momento que nós colocamos aquela caixa
naquele local ela deixou de ser nossa e
passou a ser de todos passou a ser a
nossa sociedade a nossa localidade
o ovo ultratividade Espetacular que nós
fizemos no projeto
O que é carta ao pai Natal Mas isso não
é uma carta qualquer Isso é uma carta
especial e então foi pedido aos meninos
para escrever em uma carta ao pai Natal
em que pedissem algo que não pudesse ser
comprado com dinheiro
Se tivermos tempo eles respirarem para
pensar em e para escreverem a sua carta
estas cartas foram escritas com desenhos
quebradas fechadas enviadas para casa
foram os pais que responderam a estas
estas cartas e o mais extraordinário que
os pais perceberem a quantidade de
coisas que aquelas crianças que os seus
filhos estavam valor e que não passava
por objetos que tinham ser comprados mas
impor tempo em família fazer atividades
em conjunto estarem mais tempo juntos e
lembro-me especialmente de uma carta que
dizia querido pai Natal ajuda-me a
continuar a acreditar na magia da vida e
isto é trazer a magia de cima e isto é
acreditar na magia empatia na escola
requer tempo paciência se esperança é
preciso parar Estar atento
a estar presente naquele momento e não
podemos esperar resultados imediatos
assim de repente é trazer ao de cima a
nossa humanidade e o que nós temos de
melhor tem que ter um fio com tontura
não te posso pedir determinada coisa e
depois eu fazer outra e ter outra
atitude com eles
Esse é um respeito e uma aceitação pelo
outro é uma entrega que vem dentro é
necessário semear gar e ver crescer ao
seu ritmo Sem pressa as e acreditar no
poder do amor neste amor que vem de
dentro que é sentido e não respeito nem
Shino idade se a criança
e em que recebemos das nossas crianças a
magia da Vida em que o nosso interior
brilha quando olhamos através dos olhos
delas eu digo tantas vezes tanto em casa
como que os nossos meninos na escola
vocês é que são os meus professores e eu
com vocês aprendi tanto ir ao encontro
da sua linguagem e simplificar as
palavras ajudá-la se reconhecerem as
suas forças e fraquezas e ainda assim
sentirem tem uma voz ativa e presente e
que fazem parte Como É Bom Ser Criança
em várias experiências que eu tive ao
longo do projeto uma delas foi uma
oficina de paz e foi permitir que os
pais colocar-se no lugar das crianças e
que as crianças conseguir sem olhar para
os pais com outros olhos uma das
atividades nós fizemos com eles foi o
melhor de mim e fui pedir em conjunto e
com pais e filhos que encontrassem algo
ao que pudessem fazer em prol da
comunidade em prol da sociedade em prol
da sua família estão bem melhor
é jeová Algumas crianças dependentes
eram eles conseguem sentir a farinha
aqueles pais estão maravilhados estão
envolvidos nas atividades ele sabe que
não compreendem e afinal até São
divertidos com as brincadeiras e que os
jogos nós fazemos em conjunto em que é
permitido olhar o outro e vê-lo não
através do seu olhar mas sim através do
Olhar do outro além do trabalho
desenvolvido com os pais foi possível
ainda realizar dois grupos com
professores consultados extraordinários
e paralelamente a tantas destas coisas
Ouvi uma grande atividade criar laços
fui que envolveu toda a comunidade não
são os professores como as pessoas que
estavam na rua os cafés restaurantes a
juntas foi colocar frases inspiradoras
escritas pelas crianças que ajudassem
quem sai de casa triste a ter um dia um
bocadinho melhor e olhar para a vida com
a personagens frases inspiradoras e
tocavam o coração de cada um foi
possível ainda continuar com esta
actividade durante o confinamento estas
crianças em casa com a ajuda destes
professores conseguiram escrever frases
para inspirar em da Fé Esperança as
crianças que estavam em casa antes do
seu regresso e do novo ano letivo
empatia é parar e pensar é um menino
desse
o conosco de olhar para dentro e sentir
para depois sermos capazes de escutar o
outro eu às vezes olho e vejo um sinal
vermelho um sinal de alerta uma
necessidade urgente parar e olhar para
as nossas crianças transmitimos a
inocência da vida a simplicidade ser
criança das coisas pequeninas que nós
não nos damos conta e que muitas vezes
nos passam ao lado eu não acredito que
os adultos tenham perdido essa essa
capacidade mas que estava Adormecida
e ela continua lá mas devido a nossa
correria do dia a dia do estresse e dos
nossos desafios diários
é quase como se esquecemos durante o
confinamento alguma coisa muito
importante nós tivemos tempo útil em
família tempo para estarmos presentes
tempo para escutar e ser escutado e no
outro dia numa correria entre eu saída
do trabalho a correr para uma reunião o
meu filho mais velho saído da escola e
aí para uma explicação e estamos a comer
correr e eles repente isso mãe estamos
outra vez a ficar sem tempo
o Rio para ai olha para ele e diz É
verdade filho Isso não pode acontecer o
tempo está lá nós temos que ir lá buscar
logo temos que resgatar o porque nós
precisamos dele
e por exemplo não sei casa temos
reuniões de família em todos em todos
temos algo a descer até o pai que está
longe é um espaço para falar do que me
preocupa decisões podemos tomar mesmo
que às vezes não sejam fáceis mas estas
decisões são explicadas e tenho que
fazer sentido eles tem que sentir e eu
digo-vos eles compreendem
é uma atividade Espetacular que nós
fizemos
E durante o confinamento foi o nosso
calendário da gratidão este calendário
quando foi comprado eu nem imaginaria
que ia ter tanta utilidade estava
pendurado na cozinha para nós fazermos
várias coisas
é mas somente com o outro ele surgiu
e eu surgiu durante o nosso confinamento
e tenho coisas aqui tão extraordinárias
como é que não os outros utilizávamos
era Depois do jantar analisávamos o
nosso diga que retiravam os algo de
muito bom que tivesse acontecido o nosso
dia em conjunto em família e nós temos
aqui por exemplo o cozinhar com a minha
mãe temos por exemplo a ida ao
supermercado porque eu ir ao
supermercado eu tinha que vir alguém
para ficar com os meus filhos era uma
aventura temos por exemplo de termos um
pai
e como também temos a construção de um
castelo este calendário prolongou-se
E aí
e ao longo do tempo
e ele é um três meses e foram tantas e
tantas as atividades que nós fizemos em
conjunto
se isto continuar a fazer parte da nossa
vida eu tenho aqui o junho
o e tenho o agosto e tenho Setembro EA
de continuar sempre ligada a nós e são
estes momentos e isto que vos peço
Olá a todos ajudamos a sentir empatia e
este o desafio que eu ver lance sintam a
empatia e levem-na convosco obrigada a